- Like maybe we'll make
this work, but now...
Oh, God.
I recently discovered
this old YouTube challenge
where people tried to bake cookies
blindfolded and without a recipe.
So I thought it'd be fun to challenge
my coworkers here at
BuzzFeed to do the same.
♪ One, two, three, four ♪
- Yeah, I could probably bake a cookie
without a recipe.
- [Cameraman] What about
doing it while blindfolded?
- Oh, oh.
- No!
No, I can't do that!
- I think I could definitely
bake cookies blindfolded.
- I mean, red's my color.
It matches my lipstick
so we're already off
to a great start.
- All right, everyone, let's watch me
make cookies blindfolded with no recipe.
God help me.
- Okay, I'm currently trying to figure out
where all my ingredients are.
I've got chocolate.
Wait, I have to check.
- Probably start by putting
all the dry ingredients
together, and then slowly
adding the wet ingredients.
- I'm gonna start with the hardest part
which I think is the eggs.
- Oh, that is not sugar.
(laughing) I don't know what this is.
- [Emily] This feels like
it's not a half a cup.
- All measuring has gone out the window
since I can't even see it anyway.
- [Emily] You're supposed to crack an egg
on the table not the bowl.
It's supposed to not
leave shells that way.
- Gotta be careful with vanilla.
How do I do this?
Maybe I just...
- My confidence level is plummeting.
- We've got two sizes: big and small
so maybe you're the salt.
Ew, definitely the salt.
- [Noga] I need one teaspoon of this
so I hope that's enough.
- This is feeling kind
of like cookie dough.
- More chocolate.
Can you have too much chocolate?
No.
- [Kuwilileni] I can already
tell the texture is really off.
- [Noga] This feels pretty good.
- No turning back now.
We're in the final stages
of these delicious cookies
you guys can make at home
if you've been following along.
- So I think these will cook like cookies,
but I don't think they're
gonna look like cookies.
- Cool.
- I'm just now looking down.
It looks like a baby threw up on a tray.
- You know what?
I'm curious to see what's gonna happen
so let's put them in the oven.
- They look okay.
Have I seen better cookies?
Absolutely.
- Whoo.
Oh, no.
You know it's not horrible.
They didn't quite rise to the occasion.
- [Kuwilileni] So I thought
they were gonna look
a lot better than they actually do.
They look really biscuity.
- I mean, I think these are dope.
There even gooey too.
All right, let's give it a try.
- You only live once.
Let's...
It tastes like bread with
chocolate chips in it.
On a scale of one to ten,
the cookies I made today are a five.
- I rate this cookie sheet ten out of ten.
I didn't know I needed one whole cookie,
but sometimes you just
get what you deserve.
- I think like everything went wrong.
Like, I think it tastes okay.
Like, it tastes good.
I think the chocolate makes it good,
but like the texture's not at all right.
- I'm really proud of this actually.
Yeah, they're like crispy on the ends.
This is great.
Hell, yeah.
- It probably doesn't look good,
but I like it.
(upbeat music)